everyone is like trying to accommodate
me Robin and it's so annoying it's like
they don't know what to do people don't
know whether the people should come in
Gary's in a room staring at me trying to
figure out what I'm doing we don't know
where Chris is staring at me it looks
weird we just want you to be happy and a
lot of making you happy is guessing so
there were a lot of rehearsals this
weekend yeah but you know they're not
coming in here but you know what annoys
me people rehearsing to see what makes
me happy I don't I hate it
I know but I don't want it does it annoy
you and Garrett keeps saying we just
want to make you happy yeah Gary annoys
the [__] out of you and you know what
being away from him has been the best
thing that's why I look good
tomorrow you're going to look like [__]
yeah
you know what it is Gary does nothing
wrong but everything he does is wrong I
know it's just too irritating you always
have I got it I know yeah if Gary like
even hearing Gary was like going on a
bike ride yesterday I'm like [__] you
Gary he didn't do anything wrong it's
just annoys and you know
and we get the bikes out and then we
start pedaling we go these are electric
bikes
what a wasted time exactly didn't you
also do a 90-minute walk yesterday about
an hour yeah how does she have all that
time Robin it was like this is all like
I said he was so busy yeah
that's what annoys he's busy avoiding
work
foreign